the doom games have always been
jam-packed with Easter eggs and eternal
may have them most of all so with that
in mind I try to dig out as many Easter
eggs and secrets as I could find the
best place to start is in the doom
Slayers Workshop / office / library
where there is a plethora of toy details
that could potentially be easily missed
one of the first things that may catch
your eye is the adorable portrait of the
doom Slayer and his beloved rabbit Daisy
she appeared in the original doom having
met an unfortunate end as the demons
arrived from hell while the painting is
a touching homage we live in hope that
days will return to the doom fortress as
the Slayer also has a bag of food and a
hutch ready for her arrival rumor is
that Daisy will also appear in every
level of doom eternal although so far I
found her in just the one outside the
throne room of King Novik have you found
her anywhere else well then make sure to
leave it in the comments now Daisy's
reappearance was also teased by the doom
Twitter account in a post reading
justice for Daisy and again as the
adorable little rabbit was hiding in
this cover image there has always been a
theme of referencing older age software
games with Commander Keen popping up
more than once his helmet and I guess
skull adorns the top of the bookshelf
along with his blaster his portrait also
appears as the mascot for some of the
snacks you can find littered around the
ruined earth alongside one of the
enemies of the Commander Keen series the
dopefish this strange buck-toothed fish
first appeared in 1991 s Commander Keen
secret of the Oracle but an eternal also
features as a snack food mascot as well
as apparently being a chainsaw
manufacturer if you inspect the chainsaw
from your weapon wall you can see more
of the dopefish details or you can get
much closer in the first part of the
contest base level and blow the poor guy
up for an extra life back to the Slayers
chaotic desk though next to a copy of
demonology today is an empty pizza box
featuring the handsome visage of its
creative director
Hugo Martin this box also appeared in
doom 2016 but now it seems he's
diversified his food range with his own
brand of jerky - keeping on the topic of
foodstuffs a packet of lanes takoyaki
flavor chips is also on the desk while
the name and logo is a reference to the
real world brand Lay's it's also a
reference to dooms lead concept artist
John Lane a piece of concept art there
was seemingly Dunford
sixteen has found life as doom Slayers
mouse mats and his name features wants
more on the rest of the chip bags found
back on earth
strange flavors though as you can see
the Slayers computer monitor has some
interesting file names and folders on
his desktop personally I'm most into
seeing the shotgun portraits folder and
instead of your average office toy he
has the soul cube from doom 3 just to
hanging out on his desk in Doom 3 it was
an extremely powerful weapon killing
most enemies in one hits and
replenishing the players health so
either it's an ER or it's a replica and
if not we are really hoping maybe we'll
get to use the spinning box of death
once more in dooms future one of the
comics that stood out to me in this room
was one titled hell Walker a title that
the dream Slayer is sometimes known as
it features a design and font extremely
similar to that of the Hellboy graphic
novels but instead featuring one of
eternal Marauders on the cover this
comic as well as others found in the
room are published by the Tackett comics
group Flynn fly Taggart was actually the
protagonist in the 1990s doom novels
knee-deep in the dead hell on earth
infernal sky and endgame the peculiar
cookbook underneath it featuring an
original team Cacodemons sprite is
titled Kadeem gear cooking Gdynia is an
ancient Sumerian word for Babylon and
used in doom 2016 for the first level in
which players visited Hell in Kittinger
sanctum Gdynia sanctum is also referred
to as the Blood Keith perhaps suggesting
that this is a word for one of the
locations that these demons reside and
as such is simply a recipe book for some
good old-fashioned demon's home cooking
flavors to remind them of home I guess
of course you also have the iconic doom
2016 soundtrack on vinyl a version of
both on tape and an old-school 1960s PC
that you can actually play the original
doom on that is if you find all the
secret cheat discs in the campaign
speaking of vinyls if you find any of
the world be sure to check the framed
images back base they're all tracks from
its game library including classic
bangers from Wolfenstein 3d and
Commander Keen finally tucked away on
the right is a skateboard a little odd
for a slayer to have sure but I think it
may be a reference to the bizarre time
we're doomed guy was an unlockable
character in the PC version of Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 3 now as to the
Slayers more musical hobbies doom has
always had ties to heavy metal and
playing on that there are three guitars
hung on the wall in three distinct
styles but take the count of each string
and you
six-six-six that's pretty metal for
anyone wondering about the redesign of
the plasma rifle between 2016 and
eternal the spare parts on his desk may
suggest that the pistol and plasma rifle
from the previous game and now in bits
and pieces but fun fact view the new
plasma rifle is based on the design of
the original team's weapon which itself
was made from a digitized image of the
Rambo m60 toy gun we really have come
full circle moving to this lays
impressive book collection each spine of
every book holds a reference to either a
game classical literature or the wider
gaming community here are a few choice
nods to some classic novels eat ripped
hair instead of Eat Pray Love the man in
the high argent tower instead of man in
the high castle and the kakko in the Rye
instead of The Catcher in the Rye the
middle shelf however has a lot more
modern references my buddy Superfly is a
reference to daikatana written by the
game's protagonist to honor the AI
companion to Superfly Johnson why I'm so
great by dork Norcom is of course a
reference to duke nukem devilish daggers
and other assorted pointy objects is a
nod to the game devil daggers a game
that takes a lot of inspiration from the
FPS games of the 90s and drops you into
an arena fighting hordes of demons
leAndria a brief history of
interplanetary industry is a reference
to the Leandre cooperation from the
Unreal Tournament series the Von Braun
book takes its name from one of the
interplanetary ships from System Shock
to Mesa science monthly predicting
unforeseen consequences takes its name
from half-life's Black Mesa site and the
title of the third chapter unforeseen
consequences the unit code training
manual for bomb defusal is a reference
to the original deus ex and the in-game
faction the United Nations
anti-terrorist coalition the spear of
destiny a post-war deconstruction refers
to the edge software Wolfenstein 3d
prequel the spear of destiny living with
rage is of course a connection to one of
its other FPS franchises the rage series
the strog are one of the races from the
quake series this book perhaps being a
reference to the brutal struggle ocation
process from quake 4 retcon the life and
times of flint agate seems to confirm
that the novel protagonist i mentioned
earlier is indeed no longer canon sorry
about that fly the dopefish returns
again in from nope fish to dope fish
tight hangar a guides off world travel
is a reference to a planet that appeared
in the original doom bible design
document in
preliminary parts of creation doomed the
game was going to take place on this
fictional planet rather than the moons
of Mars the next book shares a title
with the fourth and final level of
ultimate doom thy flesh consumed to pray
or not to pray is from well the pray
series interestingly though the 2006
game used it Tech for the same engine as
doom 3 and the 2017 game featured music
from the same composer as doom Mick
Gordon the vault dweller Survival Guide
is a direct reference to the Fallout
series and being safely guided by the
doom Slayer figure from the 2016 game is
a touching a Marge - markiplier as
father Clifton Morris Fischbach mark has
been a longtime doom fan and the title
of the book being how to comb your
moustache is fitting as from what I've
seen that man really did have a great -
and of course the rest of the space on
the Shelf is taken up by some classic
entries in the FPS genre dream also has
some pretty weird symbols complete with
its own demonic language but one stood
out to me as I was skewering this man
cubis on the tip of the Slayers spear
that appears to be a version of the
chemical symbol for sulfur associated
with a fire and brimstone of hell now
this may not be an easter egg but will
likely be something that not many
players will notice but if you go into
your game settings there is an option
for not only the classic gun poses but
also the classic sound effects this will
position your weapons in the middle of
the screen and let you pretend you're
playing a way shinier version of the
doom games of old
now these two eggs and references beyond
this point may have some spoilers to the
story of doom eternal so consider
yourself warned
so if you've been playing doom eternal
then you've no doubt noticed this toy
hanging out in the middle of your
fortress of doom if you be every Slayer
gate and collect every key you'll be
able to unlock the super weapon known as
the young maker this is one of the
things that ties doom eternal to doom 64
were a weapon of a similar name and
function but a much fleshy er design is
usable so it appears that a slayer may
have kept it for a rainy day
again potential spoilers but my theory
is that one of the doom mothers you
fight in doom 64 and at the climax of
the new level release alongside eternal
go on to become the card maker herself
especially since her visage is somewhat
more demonic after the completion of her
boss fight and I think my favorite
Easter Egg dye found so far takes place
during this cutscene where the doom
Slayer has his flashback as he's been
dragged to the priests and mumbling in
his own rage he says guts huge guts
which is a reference to the 16-page 1996
doom comic where our protagonist comes
face to face with a cyberdemon and
screams you are huge that means you have
huge guts rip and tear I definitely
didn't expect to be thinking about that
let's say interesting comic when I sat
through that cutscene and if you stay
tuned to the end of this video you can
find the very silly doom eternal
post-credits sequence something I missed
during my first playthrough so be sure
to stick around for that alright so
those are all the Easter eggs references
and cool things I've found so far have I
missed any almost absolutely doom has
always been full to the brim with Easter
eggs so I'm sure more will be found soon
if you have any yourself leave them in
the comment section below and we may do
a follow-up video of all the ones we
have yet to find but if you still have a
doom eternal itch we have plenty of
content for you including a nightmare
mode guide intense hoodless gameplay and
tips and tricks to keep you slaying so
for all that and more make sure you head
to GameSpot